[Applause]
hi everyone i just want to take a quick
moment to say
the holidays are approaching we all just
had a pep talk here
for ourselves i know everyone's plans
and you know it's just
it's a really difficult world right now
and i just want to say to everybody if
you feel
a lot of feelings as we say to children
they are all valid
and for one hour we want to take you
through the show today and
acknowledge the world we're in but have
some joy and optimism and have a high
note for this hour
so let's go through the show i'm really
excited it's going to be a great show
today
it's beauty junkie week still and um
we are celebrating all things beauty as
i always say
both inside and out and um
i'm gonna touch on a topic right now
that i'm not
exactly comfortable with myself but
society at large
says they are in on this
pimple popping
it makes me wanna
seriously but there is someone in the
vfs and like by the way there's that
show dr pimple popper every time i
pass by it i'm like but
people are fascinated by it and i'm not
gonna lie i love picking my own
so that doesn't gross me out that gives
me a lot of sick pleasure
so nicole
how are you today
are you ready okay i'm having a great
day i'm here
i'm talking to you it's my daughters i
have twins it's their birthday
it's it's a great day oh nicole happy
birthday mama i'm so how old are they
today
they're 16. it's a celebration for me
too when they were born
they were both over seven pounds so
it's a celebration for me too well
wow nicole this is a really wonderful
day it feels really weird to segue into
something gross like pimple popping on
this
miraculous day when you've created two
16 year olds in your belly
ugh i'm so happy for you i'm i have
eight and six i feel like i'll never get
to 16. so
thank you for sharing that everest and
we wish you the very best today
okay pro pimple popping give it to me
real quick
i can't even tell you i don't know how
this started for me
i am fascinated with watching this um
i guess growing up you know you get
pimples you pop them i don't know but
facebook decided that i might want to
watch
clips of this and it came up in the feed
and of course just like you i was like
oh my gosh this is so disgusting
but at the same time couldn't stop
watching it
um and so i don't know it keeps coming
up my feed and i just
i'm fascinated by it wow facebook really
has a way don't they
i love it um well
thank you for sharing that nicole and i
don't think you're alone
anyone in the wall raise your hand if
you're sickly
attracted or addicted to looking at it
anyone
yeah i'm with you ma'am who's shaking
her head
i but it but even on yourself no
okay no just no pimple popping period